we've recently covered quite a few
deities associated of death and it's
extremely interesting to see how
different cultures attempt to approach
and explain the natural event in Greek
mythology we see the presence of
Thanatos as almost welcomed because he
symbolizes the gentle and painless
release of death in Egypt Anubis is
somewhat of an escort ensuring that the
dead passed safely into the afterlife
but in Japan they have their own twist
on death the Shinigami meaning gods of
death or death spirits
rather than being directly responsible
and someone dies they must invite an
usher people to their own demise
the term Shinigami isn't one that
appears too much Japanese literature and
it doesn't apply to a specific God or
spirit but rather to a variety of
entities that are believed to bring
death describing their appearance can be
rather difficult as they can take a host
of different forms appearing as a god
spirit or demon like figure in early
Japanese literature the Shinigami will
never really describe this physical
entities if we look at Ningaloo or yuri
or Bunraku the ancient Japanese art of
puppet theatre the works of chicken
matzo monzaemon commonly tackled the
issue of suicide in a particular story
he describes a man and a woman
attempting to commit a double suicide
they described life has been extremely
short moon being lowered by a death God
it's unclear if their actions were
driven by the existence of a Shinigami
but in this context the word Shinigami
was almost used as an expression to
describe how short life can be
especially when we waste time worrying
about the inevitable end that awaits us
all in the classical literature of the
18th and 19th century the depictions of
the Shinigami began to change if we take
a look at the Aeon Haku monogatari often
referred to as the picture book of a
hundred stories it covers a host of
different yokai and supernatural
entities there is a story titled
Shinigami and in this story the
Shinigami is described as the spirit of
someone who passed but still harbored
bad intent quite similar to how we would
describe a ghost or a poltergeist the
spirit would lead the living along a bad
path and take them to places where
previous steps had occurred they were
known to lead those who were
contemplating suicide to places where
others had previously hung themselves in
the hope that history would repeat it
of this form of Shinigami was believed
to possess people and slowly break their
will
causing them to want to die in later
years it was believed that several
things would happen to someone who was
possessed by this particular type of
spirit they would either find it
extremely difficult to tell the truth
when asked questions or find it almost
impossible to speak at all we can almost
assume that these are techniques used by
the Shinigami to alienate their hosts
from friends and family making it much
harder for them to seek help it's
believed that they could invade a
person's thoughts forcing them to relive
every horrible thing they had ever done
until it became so much that death was
the only release the Izanagi
and the Izanami are what many consider
to be examples of the very first
Shinigami they were the eight pairs of
brother and sister deities that appeared
when the earth was created and they were
often associated with both creation and
death the Shinigami are quite similar to
the other colony of the Shinto religion
but their history doesn't stretch as far
back because after all they are
relatively recent invention
it wasn't until Japan came into contact
with the West and their ideas of
particular gods associated of death that
the idea of the Shinigami really began
to grow and develop where it was common
for Western cultures to have very few
cards associated of death in Japan there
were many Shinigami and they often
worked in groups and pairs there was an
interesting tale about a man who is fed
up with his life and so he contemplates
suicide but before he is able to do so
he is visited by Shinigami
who tells him that his time has not come
yet the spirit explained to the man that
each person's life is measured on the
candle and once the flame burns out that
person dies these depictions differ
drastically and contradict the early
depictions of the Shinigami who appeared
more as vengeful spirits it's very clear
that in this story they have no control
over who lives and who dies they're
essentially told when a person's time
has come to an end
but perhaps they are even able to sense
when a person's time is near when the
figurative candle is about to burn out
to stop the man end in his life the
Shinigami tells him how he could become
very rich the man would pretend to be a
doctor who would claim he could cure any
disease he was given a magical phrase of
words that would send any Shinigami back
to the underworld and thus lengthen
someone's life the phrase would only
work if the Shinigami was sitting at the
foot of someone's bed
if they were at the head of the bed the
magical phrase would only cause a sick
person to die with his newfound
knowledge the man indeed grew very rich
and one day when visiting a patient he
saw the Shinigami at the head of the
patients bed the family begged the man
to help and offer the client in several
offers the family offered an amount of
money so large that the man was consumed
by greed when the Shinigami fell asleep
the patient swapped the ends of the bed
and the magical words sent the spirit
back to the underworld when the man
arrived home the same Shinigami was
waiting for him infuriated of what he
had just done the Shinigami told the man
that all would be forgotten if they went
for a drink to celebrate the man's newly
earned fortune the man of course agreed
not knowing that he had just fallen for
a trick he was taken to a building
filled with candles and he was shown his
own Candle which was nearly burnt out
because of his actions
the man was told he could extend his
life by transferring the wick and the
wax of his candle to another but of
course this was another trick the man
failed dropping his candle and dying
this is a story that I really enjoy
because not only does it show us that
the Shinigami are unpredictable but they
seem to have their own distinct
personalities the first Shinigami
appeared as quite friendly explaining to
the man how death worked and even
helping him improve his life the
following spirit said the man came
across did not seem to be too concerned
of the fact that he was sending them
back to the underworld but it was a lost
Shinigami he was angered by his actions
swear in revenge against the man and
ultimately taken the man's life as a
payment for the soul he had stopped him
acquiring now I know you fans of the
Death Note anime and manga had been
waiting for this video for a while and a
video discussed in the Shinigami
wouldn't exactly be complete without
taking and look at their recent
depictions and transformations I had
previously never read or watched if no
but I had heard of the name and it
wasn't until watching the Netflix movie
adaptation that I even came across the
Shinigami the Shinigami appear as demon
like gods who write the names of mortals
in books known as death notes causing
them to die in the sixth end their own
life Shinigami are not responsible for
every death that occurs but they can
sometimes end their life sooner than
intended
the character known as Ryoga is quite a
curious Shinigami who out of boredom
drops one of these said death notes in
to the human world with instructions on
how it can be used those who find the
book are essentially entered into a
bargain or a pact with Ryoga where he
agrees to kill anyone whose name is
written in the book in the desired
manner
Ryoga appears to feel no apathy for
those who find the book as they
essentially just the means for him to
extend his own life but he doesn't
mention several times that he finds
humans and their behavior extremely
interesting the individuals who enter
into an agreement of react are told if
they no longer desire to be the keeper
of the book then they can pass it along
to someone else or they can separate
themselves from the book for seven days
once the seven days are up Ryo could
find a new person to assume the role as
keeper of the book those who find the
book are often consumed by the power it
comes with and ultimately the Death Note
is responsible for their own death the
Shinigami in Death Note do also vary in
appearance if we take react as an
example he has a long thin appendages
and a ghoulish like appearance he's head
and neck appeared to be stitched to his
body and he almost reminds me of Jack
Skellington from The Nightmare Before
Christmas only much more menacing and
deadly there are quite a few Shinigami
that appear in the series and the ones
similarity and appearance that they all
seem to share is that they will resemble
corpses and I guess when you think about
it that isn't too out of the ordinary
for gods of death if these depictions of
the Shinigami are something that
interests you then I suggest you either
check out the enemy of the manga or
perhaps even the Netflix movie if bad
movies are something you enjoy the
deities surrounding death in other
cultures are often shown to be selfless
individuals who perform a thankless task
I guess one of the main reasons I find
the Shinigami so interesting is because
they differ drastically not only because
of the sheer amount of them that exist
but they seem to have their own distinct
personalities the role that the
Shinigami played drastically changed
over the years in Japan in early
Japanese culture they were used to
explain someone dying particularly the
act of suicide but they soon began to
manifest as vengeful spirits who were
capable of possessing people and driving
them insane until the early release was
there
in the most recent depictions they
appear as demon like gods who strike
bargains of mortals as a means of
extending their own lives the Shinigami
are most definitely a mixed bag there
are those who choose to help people as
they transition into the underworld
there are those who seek revenge and
enjoy causing death and there are those
who use the lives of mortals as
bargaining tools as a means to extend
their own existence whether you see the
Shinigami as spirits demons or gods
they're extremely intriguing figures who
give us a different outlook on deities
surrounding death
once again I'd like to thank all the
patrons who voted on this week's video
and for all the support you've given me
if you guys interested in becoming a
patron and having a choice in one of the
videos I make every week then I'll leave
a link in the description as well as an
end screen that you guys can click on
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]